All right.
Hello and welcome, everyone.
This is ActInf livestream number 47.0.
It is August 3rd, 2022.
Welcome to the Active Inference
Institute.
We are a participatory online
lab and institute
that is communicating, learning
and practicing applied active inference.
You can find us
at some of the links on the slide.
This is a recorded and archived and
transcribed and published live stream.
So please provide us with feedback
so we can improve our work.
All backgrounds
and perspectives are welcome
and we'll be following video
etiquette for livestreams.
All active inference institute
activities are participatory, so
do let us know if you want to contribute
or get involved.
Head over to active inference storage.
And click the links to participate
directly and to learn more.
Well, we are about to
set off on a odd numbered
and unique adventure in 47.
We're going to be discussing
and juxtaposing
not one paper as per usual,
but have a multiple eyes open
approach towards two papers
in this situation.
We're going to be learning and discussing
in a juxtaposed fashion
two papers, "Active Inference and Abduction"
in 2021 by Ahti-Veikko
Pietarinen and Majid D. Beni.
Also, we'll be discussing "Enactive-Dynamic Social Cognition
and Active Inference" by Inês
Hipólito and Thomas van Es,
also from 2021.
All videos, dot zeros
and otherwise are introductions
to these ideas in additional context,
not a review or evaluation or final word.
And we are going to consistently,
we hope, use this coloration
of a light read for the abducted paper
and a light blue for the inactive,
leaving the space open
for new colors and combinations
to arise that demonstrate
some areas of synthesis.
And we're going to talk in this dark zero
with some big questions
and go over our aims,
as well as reading in between those aims,
which is a little bit different
than many live streams.
We're then going to provide overview
information on each paper
in terms of the aims,
the claims, the roadmap and the abstract.
Well, then move to a background
and context section that will include
a lot of information on an action
semiotics abducted of logic and so on.
Well, then move into a juxtaposition
of the two papers
and we're going to have a lot of time
to discuss with hopefully
multiple authors in the upcoming
discussions .1.2 and maybe beyond.
So today,
we wanted to bring a big picture context
and talk about some very interesting
threads,
provide a little bit of background
that helps one enter into this space
and then provide initial
juxtaposing action and run
through these papers that again,
we'll just get somebody excited
to read the papers, dove in more deeply
and bring their own perspective
to bear on these
very interesting topics. So
we'll move to the introductions.
I'm Daniel.
I'm a researcher in California
and I'll talk
more about what's exciting in the coming
slides.
All positive.
Good morning.
My name is Dean in Calgary
and I guess I was
maybe the the work mind that tried
to put this idea together
and maybe change a little bit.
The way that we look at active inference
by trying to pull
two different papers of seeming seemingly
different folk focuses
and then both of those also
incorporating the use of active inference
as a methodology
to situationally analyze.
And so what are the implications
for that?
So I find that really kind of exciting
and I'll pass and received.
So thank you.
Yes, Stephen.
Here I am in Toronto, Canada,
and I'm really interested
in about both of these papers
because they both speak a lot to kind
of participatory approaches in general.
And the idea of how people
are engaging in the world.
So the questions around
in action is,
is really relevant
as is the action piece. So
while they're both quite different
papers,
they're both speaking
to me quite strongly.
So that's really interesting.
So I'm looking forward
to being able to sort of explore that.
I'm, I'm work with participatory
theater, community
psychology,
community development and multi scale
development processes,
and I'm really excited to
just see how this scientific
take can be a more
what might be called a practice
based participate
truly question that I've been looking at,
so I'll pass it back to Daniel.
Excellent.
Thank you both.
And Dean, thanks again for the many month
journey, the many email and month
and message journey that we've walked,
because I do hope this will
unfold and include
in a way that is taking live streams
and the kind of materials that we're working through beyond where we have gone.
And in spirit of that, I will
pass the dean to introduce
some of the big questions here.
Well, if you've got a pull to papers
that don't seem
to have a heck of a lot in common
in terms of their subject matter,
you're going to have to come at it
from a little bit of a different angle
in terms of not just ferreting out
what's within a paper,
but how those papers might be compared.
So we pulled together
some some questions around the idea
of what role
as a situational analysis, this
either tool or reality method,
active inference
might play in playing things
that seem to be a long ways
away and apart and entangle them.
And so questions were basically,
can active interest be both
something that pulls or contains
or bounds something
and also be
the thing bounded or being gripped?
What is active evidence or what is active
interest is both.
The thing being contained,
say a partition or
line in a table and the cell
so that the actual gap
that we can actually put more information
into what that look like,
what it would look like, both
as a constraint
and a separator simultaneously.
And I think it's that mutuality piece
that we're going to try to tease out
in the next few live streams
and what is similar or different
in getting a grip on models
and a different process,
which is modeling.
Thank you, Steven.
Stephen,
do you want to add anything here?
No, I think that that covers a lot of it.
The only thing that that X that's
there is so denoting
no can active inference models modeling
frameworks.
So this this
this contextualization of the term.
So it comes into play, but we're going to
talk about that a bit later.
So yeah. Thanks. Awesome.
And this is one of potentially
the first our aims slides
because it is hopefully going
to help to come back to this level.
The mean
here represents this live stream
bringing together
the two papers in a way
where we've had one hand clapping.
Now we're going to bring that together
into two.
You can hear the sound
coming out of the live stream already,
especially if you're listening.
Dean, what would you describe
about our aims or how would you
summarize
one other note I'll add about alternate
aims is we want it to be comprehensive,
but also to have videos
that are listenable
and have reasonable temporal duration.
So there will be many slides
that will have a lot of text copied
out of the paper and will merely note
pause the video if you'd like to read.
But we're just going to move on
from many of the text slides.
We just really wanted to make sure
that all the text was there and visible,
but we're not going to read everything.
So please, Dean, summarize what of these
aims you'd like to talk about.
I'm just going to talk about this sort of
the root of each one of these bullets,
which is take a closer
look at the realism instrument
instrumentalist of debate.
I don't have to go into what that is
if you're going to participate in it.
You know, we're describing reinforce
a two eyes open approach where one eye
takes in the pair of active inference
papers, the inactive denote
dynamic social condition and abduction,
while the other man,
the other eye manifests active instances
that as an integrator of both
because we think that
it actually can do that without blending.
You can actually cause a reaver, a braid,
and then the third bullet
is make explicit the absolute necessity
if we're going to do those
first two things of understanding
the temporal depth of models
that would actually
incorporate two papers of seeming distant
topics
as we make active inference
into two different subjects.
And then just while we did,
is pulled out different
things
that the authors noted about your picks.
Thank you.
And Steven, if you could carry forth
with reading in between
those aims or adding anything
you'd like from this slide.
Yeah.
Thanks, Daniel. So,
you know, one set of authors says,
you know, is really looking
at instrumental ism and, you know, it's
a valid scientific perspective.
But no, there is then describes,
you know, this question
about the road towards
realism and Mormonism.
So, you know,
where the idea is that in one paper,
the instrumental ism
is is the way to sort of punch
or to to to sort of hold ourselves
in this scientific work.
Well, that can be challenged.
And we would
we would see ways that we might need to
to loosen that when we get into
participatory approaches.
So something in between
which loosens that scientific space
and the practice space.
So the same with the second point
where okay is, is
instrumental ism,
you know, the way forward.
So what, what constitutes the pages
when living in in these
what constitutes living beings
and how do we resolve which way forward?
So if there's if
there are contradictions,
should we reconcile them
if we're in a team trying to use this,
should we just live with them
and just move forward
or where
should we actually highlight them?
So this is in a way
trying to think in an outside of
maybe this sort of laser
focus on the scientific
philosophical point and saying, okay,
when we try to bring these into a team
context,
should we would we lose in some of that?
So and so just it just mentions here
to give an application.
Should we
then also think about active inference
being prefaced or suffix,
you know, adaptive active inference,
effective active inference or active
inference modeling, you know, is
how important is that clarification to.
So then also think about how
the instrument sense of realism piece
might be utilized in these other ways.
Do we need to position,
you know, fully in one, fully on another?
And if we're in between, you know, can
there be greater or lesser access
to knowing based on the contexts
so often in participatory
work of different types of practices?
You know, the context is key.
And then this sort of speaks a little bit
to my own idea of the co-creative work.
And I know that
Daniel is very much with teams
and teams very much with transformation.
You know, often there
there's a co-creation pieces.
There's a bit where you want to support
the butterfly without crushing it.
There's something quite delicate there.
So how can we at times
doing this into spaces
where it's a co-creative space,
where there's modeling happening
in a more subtle, contextual way?
And while we have these
scientific definitions
and strategic designs and hard analysis
and they're useful,
we don't want them to crush
what's happening.
And there's a couple of pictures there
that sort of speak to that and I'll pass
you over to Dean.
Maybe you can speak to the sampling,
the waters in between
and the mind, the gap.
Well, I think I think
that was beautiful exploration.
And I think when if
and when the authors are able to come on,
that will be something that will now
be able to put some color to.
I think maybe I think we put some anchors
in the ground, but we haven't said
how much how much flow can go between
those different nodes.
And that's what I think we wanted
to establish right here, is the between
this line two times, like it says,
mind the gap.
That's
the only thing that can carry a subway.
All right.
Because you're
not paying attention to the gap.
And I think the sampling of the waters
in between does the same thing, except
that it provides a little different
subtle difference in terms
of the fluidity of those kinds of gaps.
So I think it would be really interesting
if we if we use that as our portal into
how we might bring things together
and make them dance
when they otherwise would be sitting
on chairs on opposite sides of the room.
That might be an interesting conversation
to start in.
The DOT wanted to.
Thank you both.
And the only comment I'll add here
is this discussion
we've been having on the adjectives
that preface
the adaptive affective, etc.,
active inference.
And then also, Steven,
the focus you've brought to the suffix
that x in brackets active inference model
as one instance or case or realization
active inference framework active
inference process theory what what
follows and this really reminds me
of left branching and right
branching clauses in grammar and syntax
and that there's a base clause.
What is our base clause and then what
branches before, during and after.
I think there's a very rich space
and I really like these embodied
and flux based metaphors
that help us understand
so much so into the paper overviews.
This will just be some metadata
and descriptions on the papers
before we pull back
to the background in context
and then move forward into the papers
running through their main points.
So we're not going to read the abstracts.
They're both,
of course, available for these papers.
Here is the abstract for active inference
and abduction.
Here's the abstract for inactive dynamic
social cognition and active
inference.
Here are the keywords
for both of these papers.
The inactive paper has the keywords
social cognition, niche construction,
active inference, theory of mind
in activism and Dynamical Systems Theory.
The Abduction
Paper has the keywords abduction,
active inference, free energy, principle,
first and blanket triadic relations
and pairs.
Let's go to the aims of and the claims
of the abduction paper.
So, Dean, would you like to cover
any of the aims of the abduction paper?
I What I would like to do
is just sort of foretell what
both of both papers want to aim at
and that is you'll see
a keyword and the second bullet
of this one, which is alliance.
And then there are words
that you're going to see in the other
paper where they're again saying,
we want things to come together,
but we want to be careful
in how we describe that coming together.
We don't want it to be perceived
metaphorically as a blending,
as an undoing of two,
two or more things
that we believe have an associative
relationship.
And so I think when you're going through
the aims of the two papers, if you
if you kind of step back a little bit,
you'll see that
the authors of both papers are
doing a hard
explanation on what relationship
they want us to pay attention to.
And so that's something
that they both paper share.
It's the heavy emphasis on relationship.
Great point.
And they both are very richly
and powerfully written.
And here we see Alliance and Allegiance.
And certainly there's going to be
a lot of discussion in both the papers
about integrating disparate or partially
related ontologies and vocabulary sets
and different thinkers, different
threads of intellectual development.
These quotes from the paper can be read
and of course
are expanded upon in the paper.
But as Dean said,
this paper's focus is on the intellectual
alliance between active inference
and free energy principle.
FP And primarily the work of C.S.
Peirce in terms of semiotics,
pragmatics, Marxism, objective logic.
That is the aim.
Synthesis is bringing those two together
in a way that's synergistic and
is providing meaning. Stephen
Yeah, and just
following on from what you're saying,
the both these papers and particularly
the objective one is
it gives a way to look at areas
that are really hard
to simulate for computers.
And the way that abduction happens over
particularly with humans,
is very sophisticated.
And I think it's really helpful to
then see semiotics, which is actually
used a lot in its scenography
and set design pragmatism.
So go into this with it
with a with a really
a theory that transcends science.
Often
it is often used in other fields like
the natural sciences as some use for it,
but it's often used in the humanities.
So I think this is
speaking to that piece about
what is it that is revealed, that kind
of secret sauce, that kind of hidden soul
which is normally missing in action,
is also something that's like that
awesome.
Claims
of the paper or throughout the paper.
But just to highlight
some of the key claims,
they're claiming that that aim that
they set out to make between the work
of active inference and the abduction
and semiotic perspective appears.
They're claiming that that is feasible
and that they are providing
an initial sketch for it
in this theoretical theoretical
integration of the new in the old,
something red, something blue,
something new, something old.
And the two frameworks,
the new and the old respectively,
are the modern instantiation
of neuroscience and cognitive science,
represented by a free energy principle
and on the old,
a historically accurate and precise
interpretation of objective inference,
including the importance
of the economy, of research,
all things
that we're going to come back to.
Just wanted to clarify the claims there.
Can I just add one.
Place.
For a quick
so theoretical integration there?
I mean, from what if you can think back
to when we were talking about our aims,
now the question is with
this is what the authors are saying.
What we're wondering is,
does that make active inference
both the integration product
and the integrator the process?
And again, I want to
I want to kind of tease back
that one step, because I think that's
going to happen again.
When we look at the other paper,
they'll use different nomenclature,
but they're going to say the same thing.
And again, it's it's
hard to see the commonality
is unless you and I,
you don't have to make them up.
You just have to notice them in
in the two different types of forests.
And a point on that.
They're
both, in a way, using active inference
as an integrator
as well as as a differentiator.
We're making an integrated model
of internal
and external and blanket states
by differentiating them.
And then, of course, integration
and differentiation also have a joint
usage in mathematics with the integral
and the derivative notation.
So there's going to be a lot of things
coming together,
steaming your hands to up. Yes, please.
Yeah. Just one thing as well.
I think this is really helpful
to talk about neuroscience
in this computational neuroscience
and to highlight that
because I think something that
is the reality in the world
out there, the culture out there where
where these ideas are circulating
is that neuroscience
is turned on its head,
basically by active influence.
Neuroscience as a field, as people
understand it, is some sort of
deductive
process of stuff coming in
and then being evaluated and
concretized,
as opposed to this predictive journey.
So I think it's really, really useful
because this is
this is something that we all face.
And I think I also have noticed
when I've spoken to some neuroscientists,
they've actually had like
an existential crisis and shifted
partly often
by coming up with an active claims
and seeing really active
claims are there.
How can their work with neuroscience
be so held together?
So there's this, there's this.
There's a piece here
that relates to the general.
And that general piece is more important
when we start to bring active influence
out from the specialist areas
where it's kind of enclaves
and it's rules of the game are known, and
you're into the areas
where people say, neuroscience, well,
I know what that means and off you go.
So thanks. Great. Thank you.
The paper has relatively few sections.
It has an introduction.
It then presents a pairing
of active inference
in the light of abduction.
Abduction
in the light of active inference.
Slightly oblique reference
to nothing in biology makes sense
except in the light of evolution,
or except in the light of something.
And these are two lights
back to that island.
What is the space between?
And then there's a discussion
on the economy of research
and it's free energy naturalization
and the conclusion
and the pierce rabbit holes run deep.
We're going to go into a few soon
and onto the inactive paper.
So here we're going to be describing
the AIMS, claims and roadmap
of the inactive, dynamic social cognition
and active inference paper.
The paper presents a two fold
aim to dissect new accounts
that blend in activism
with inferential accounts
and explain why doing so involves
contradiction is the first aim.
And the second aim is to offer
the only reasonable account linking
in activism and inferential accounts,
especially on this case
of social cognition.
So, yes, please.
Yes, I was hoping could you
now turn the word linking purple
for us? Yes.
Thank you. Yes.
If now we have different ways
of describing between that Stephen
did a lovely job of emphasizing
before we actually started looking at the
the papers themselves.
Yeah. It's a between.
Yeah it's awesome.
And it is actually through your request
and the slides platform,
it becomes
inactive, dynamic social stigma, logic.
And so that's a proof
of concept for what.
But this is the aims of this paper.
They also have many claims
articulated throughout the discussion
and they actually use some very clear
notation to describe the specific claims
from other work and from their own work,
and about which claims and hypotheses
have which logical relationship
they're going to make.
Claims about the nature of cognition
and its embodied basis.
They're going to be discussing
some of the claims
related to the human social cognitive
niche and talking about
the importance of relationship
inculturation niche construction.
And then they're going to be talking
about theory of mind time
and about the compatibility
or contradictions associated with linking
inactive claims with theory of mind
or inferential accounts.
The paper's roadmap lays out
many of these aims and claims
quite clearly.
They begin with an introduction
and introduce
a recent, though influential work
in the active inference field,
which is the thinking through other minds
framework team.
And they, as they say,
dissect this accounts
to try to tease apart
the way that in their view,
the inactive and the inferential counts
were brought together.
They also have a figure
describing a mark up blanket,
which is going to be a concept
that place Kealy in both of the papers,
section two Something's got to give,
rejecting inactive inference
through other minds,
they're going to utilize two assumptions,
namely that social cognition
reduces to mental representation,
and two, that social cognition
is hardwired from birth.
And they're going to disagree
with both of these assumptions.
And in their opposition
to these assumptions supported by sub
claims and evidence
that is going to lead them to their
broader conclusions, they're going to
use dynamical systems theory
and talk about how DST
can be linked with in activism in terms
of its compatibility and what these two
frameworks offer each other
within an instrumentalist reading.
And then they're going to discuss
active inference specifically
in the context of dynamical systems
theory on one hand,
and in active cognition, social cognition
on the other hand.
That's the inactive, dynamic hyphenation
they'll describe with a few figures
about similarities and differences
between social and action
generally as conceptualized
outside of active inference.
And then they're going to introduce
visually how active inference
enriches that picture.
And then they have a very interesting
table distinguishing
between are among phenomena observed
in the natural world and observe behavior
in the natural world.
Okay, awesome to run through the papers
that way.
Now let us move to the background
and context section.
So in this section of the zero,
we're going to use some quotes
from the paper for sure,
but we're also going to pull a step back
and demonstrate
just the tip of the iceberg
of the scholarship
and the research that we carried out
leading up to this point,
hopefully
to excite the listener or reader
and to provide some context into these
very deep threads
that are going to be approached
and approximated in the papers.
I'll provide a first note here or Dean,
please go for it.
It's just a guess.
I think it's a spectacular moment
to say, okay, so background and context.
So we're talking maybe the temporal
and the physical setting.
So that's now something
that we can situationally analyze.
And again,
just matter whether you use active
inference or whether you use a cast model
or whether you use
professional initiatives programing.
Bottom line is
everybody is trying to figure out
what the situation is through an analysis
method.
And I would imagine
that every one of those methods
has a greater or lesser viability D
depending upon what the situation,
both temporally and physically is.
So I think that's
the critical thing is we're not saying
that each of these papers are good
or bad.
We're saying that each of these papers
has a focus on a different
background
context combination, minimum of two.
So now if we pull the two things
together, we can't say
that that it's going to be the same thing
that we're going to come up with, that
our aims as people who have now looked
at the two papers side by each,
that's
going to create a whole new entity.
Thank you.
To lead
off this background
and contextualizing section, I wanted to
invoke one of my favorite artists
and poets, William Blake.
And Blake
wrote Controversies are positives.
A negation is not a contrary
negations are not contrary.
Contreras Mutually exist,
but negations exist not exceptions
and objections and unbelief exist not,
nor shall
they ever be organized forever and ever
and quote
Contreras in this Blake
in fourfold logical framework,
in fact, are part of a dialectic
and they exist
as a function of each other,
like convex and concave, or like gravity
and radiation, as Buckminster
Fuller might take it towards.
And so negations
in this poetical framework
are those which exist not,
whereas A and B can be on the contrary,
whereas A and not A
have a different logical relationship.
And this kind of fourfold
logical approach
to recognizing the state space
and the truth claims
that multiple all juxtaposed
assertions can have with among each other
is also for staged
in a lot of world knowledge traditions.
For example, the Carter Scotty.
And this is a logical tool and method
that's been applied for a very long time
in the the dharmic traditions
of the Indian context
wanted to provide that.
And also
with these images which either of you are
welcome to explore,
what does one hand-clapping
or a person doing
the splits have to do with contradiction
in negation? Yes.
Yeah.
I mean, regarding contradiction as well.
And I think this points to the kind of
the contextual piece,
the situational analysis piece is
there's there's the situation in inside
which
there's there's there's
the contradictions are constructed,
if that makes sense.
And that's also embodied
and enacted to our life.
So it might well be as a baby,
we know the morphology of the child
a different stages
in different contexts gives the ways
to establish situational awareness
and the contradictions within that
as things become codified.
So you've got these,
these, these situational
processes are kind of
what we're doing in this ongoing
modeling flow,
the kind of the fields of practice
in these different papers
that underpin them in activist
fields are practice or they are the more
computational fields of practice.
They've, they're what we kind of embody
and we get into them, we learn.
And that's what we're kind of intuitively
modeling in a way.
We get a feel for how we should model
being in these situations,
the contradictions,
but that modeling often
and this is the danger where it gets
overpowered by someone with their model.
I, someone is in their world
modeling what it's like to be themselves
or trying to process it.
They go and see a counselor
with their model
and that model is
being used to fit them to the model.
And then that counselor will tell us
what their problem is, how it's framed.
So I think this model of modeling
is quite relevant here because, you know,
once these contradictions
are established, it might
well be that there's a model created
within that domain and then someone
who's not necessarily in that
domain can be ascribe to the model.
They don't know what the game is.
They're not in the process
and the model takes over.
So that sort of switches
over to the splits because then, okay,
we've got two things together.
We were talking about is this that
you open up and you've got a stance
of some sort and at some point it's like,
that's not a stance, brother.
That's that,
that's a split you got into that you're
going to have to be careful, right?
So you've gone into this idea
that you're opening things up
now where they one thing to start with
with a stance
that they were held in some ways
have they split in a way
where they're now isolated
from each other, you know,
and I suppose we're trying to hopefully
find a way to neither push them into one,
neither have split,
maybe have a stance in between
that is somehow agile
and relates in this case
to realism, instrumental ism,
but kind of echoes
some broad, broad themes.
Thank you, Dean.
Just real quick
on a lot of people for the yoga
Yogi Berra ism,
when you see a fork in the road, take it.
And I know that with the
with a lot of the the term joined
has come up a lot
join probability for example.
And so the idea of split here
is a really good one, metaphorically
speaking, because if you are looking
at something with active inference
and you are assuming that in a
T experiment you have to go
left or right, well, human beings
can see a fork in the road and take it.
That's kind of the standing joke.
If you see a fork in my legs, take them.
Don't necessarily.
You have to choose A or B,
you can take the whole thing.
And I think that's what Blake is trying
to point out with this exercise.
And so is that a contradiction?
No bites of utensil on the road.
I can take it.
But if I'm not open to the idea,
that fork doesn't
only mean left or right,
then I'm already self limited
in terms of what I am testing,
what I'm situationally analyze.
Thank you.
Both are right into the more direct
keyword pieces.
So in action from those definitions
dot net site
and actions, one of the possible ways
of organizing knowledge
and the forms of interaction
with the world in active knowledge
is knowledge that comes through action
and is constructed on motor skills
such as manipulating objects,
riding a bicycle or playing a sport.
That's just one of many definitions
that have been provided.
We've also had several
live streams and paper discussions
on inaction and active inference.
For example, in active live
stream number six, way back when in 2020,
we discussed Ramstad at all
a tale of two densities.
Active inference is an active inference.
In 2021
we discussed a paper also of Hippolyta
all embodied, skillful performance
where the action is.
And interestingly for staging
in some ways this very discussion.
Here's a slide from
that live stream
with of the Polito paper.
And here we had the Pearson Triad
and we had the symbolism
and the semiotics
and the references to French.
So we actually were talking about the
very related concept of representation
and indeed those who support
and or reject
and or find contradiction in linkage,
all of the above
the discussion around in activism
and the inferential accounts
is going to hinge
very much on the question
of representation
and cognitive representations.
What those are, where
or if they exist, and so on.
That was left from 23.
Also from this paper of Angadi at all,
they lay out just visually, we're going
to see more representation soon.
In their view,
some of the distinctions between
traditional social cognition
and inactive social cognition.
And so rather than just a visual
interpretation of the image, maybe Diem,
would you like to provide it?
No way to you done it.
Okay, so here, here.
What I see is that in the traditional
social cognitive, inferential accounts,
the gears are turning inside the brain.
And then there's perception
action loops and linkages
that connect social entities
that are in their body.
But the body is seen as like an interface
for that kind of information
transfer, one extreme stance
or simple visual representation.
And then here in contrast, we see like
the gears are everywhere, including
in the environment in the niche,
in the space between and that.
Yes, the brain is doing things,
but also it's part of an enacted system
that is implementing this in culture
social
cognitive process
a little bit more in a holistic framing.
So. Dean Yes.
Yeah.
I was just going to say in a minute
we're going to look at what
the abduction thing talks about,
but for now,
I would like people just to sort of
hold in their mind the idea that
this is speaking
to a type of temporal depth.
But that temporal depth is vertical.
I think abduction,
looking at longer timelines
or for hundreds of years
is more horizontal.
So just keep in mind that we're talking
temporal depth, but the focus is
on a vertical or a deep temporal depth
instead of a wide
lateral temporal depth.
So they both matter,
but they're orthogonal.
Doesn't mean that they're in conflict
with one another.
It just means they're going in
different directions.
That's all I want to say, that.
It's funny,
left and right or west and east.
Those are contrary directions, but
they're not negative three directions.
And so right there is where we start
to see like how or finality or sparsity
or conditional independence
granted by a markov blanket, for example,
how those can be seen in the framework
of contrary to though not negations.
Steven
that gear in the
in the right hand diagram there
the gear in between
that can have temporal depth
that can have this mind body environment
peace is definitely there like you say
and and obviously makes
as a unit of analysis
that's really challenging
and I would also put in there
as the gear words
words are a twitch
twitch in of our voice box is giving us
words in space around us.
So, you know,
they're being used as tools as well.
So suddenly we're much more enmeshed,
even if it's just speech.
Yeah.
And it takes time for the speech
to travel through the Internet
and through space and time.
A little bit
more depth on social in action.
This in action research
resource describes
several meanings and senses
of inaction in the performative,
in the bringing forth senses.
So please read
and also a really nice 2009
paper in cognitive semiotics
by De Bruin and Dunn
discuss some of the relationships
of in activism, in social cognition.
And they did
an excellent job of summarizing what
the inferential
and the in activist accounts
can bring together
and sort of discuss that linkage.
Yes, please. Dean.
Yeah,
I've read that paper because I found it.
And here's an interesting thing.
If they're going to use a
bridge metaphor,
I think an activist does have a bridge.
It's just a vertical bridge.
It's the side of a building going up.
And so
not it
not not to criticize my favorite year,
but I think there is a gap
and there is an ability to span.
It's just that it's going vertical.
It's not going
traditionally side to side.
Awesome.
So on to a little bit of depth
into abduction and semiotics.
Well, we had quite the learning journey
together
and the abduction paper
with one or one and a half
or even two of the authors being true
person
experts provided many details.
Pierce was a prolific writer
and thinker and collaborator,
and also much of the work
was unpublished, which means that
there are some arcane reference systems
and not all of it is hyper accessible.
We found the Commons work site
to be immensely useful
in providing many definitions,
as well as links to resources.
Dean, would you like to summarize
anything on this page?
Nothing other than if you if you
if you are interested in pragmatism
and you want to get past William
James, actually, William
James and Charles Pierce had a bit of a
they were they were maybe 150 years ago,
the first conflict years around
how things work.
It's actually really it's an amazing
takeoff point in terms of how people
who appear
to be in competition with one another
actually make one another smarter.
But in fact, a lot of the things
a lot of the ideas
that were 150 years
later are now looking back on.
We would have to say
they may have felt
they were in competition
with one another,
but I think what they were doing
was relaying or somehow
building a better part of
because they were always
looking at things as
through the same eyes,
they had both eyes open.
So that's
how I'll just say go to the common side.
It's, it's good.
Yeah, it's great. This representation,
ironically,
appropriately, is of the well known
Pearson triad
semiotic framework, where a stop sign
is called the representation,
the represented instance, the physical
stop sign, the real stop sign.
The object is the message
cars must stop here
and the interpreted is
I should stop here.
And so that's where we get that entity
agency.
I found a interesting paper
about the user interface,
which brings some of these truly timeless
discussions on semiotics and logic
into a digital context.
They're applying that same meiosis
to the user interface metaphor.
One could imagine if that were
a stop sign in the real world,
or if it were a button on a website
in a user interface context.
And anyone may pause
and read some of these
very excellent selections from quotes and
lectures given
on how copies, signs and symbols
are linked through logic and some meiosis
lot here, but we'll carry on to abduction
specifically.
So this was a little bit on Pierce
and the definition
of semiotics
as opposed to the science of things.
The more positive sciences
and the science of forms
which are the more formal sciences,
what is abductor of reasoning?
This was very fascinating to explore.
This is a quote from the abduction paper
they wrote It is common
in the secondary literature, e.g.
that building on Pierce
to conceive abduction as occurring
in two parts or two kinds
generative abduction
and selective abduction.
Here's
another perspective on the two types
or the two varietals or two components
to stroke engine of abduction
from the Stanford
Encyclopedia of Philosophy.
They wrote
in the philosophical literature,
The term abduction is used in two related
but different senses.
In both senses,
the term refers to explanatory reasoning
in the historically first sense.
It refers to the place of explanatory
reasoning in generating hypotheses
that's generative abduction,
while in the second sense,
which is the sense
which it is used
most frequently in the modern literature,
it refers to the place of explanatory
reasoning, justifying
or evaluating
in enumerated set of hypotheses.
And in a sense, it makes it makes sense.
The content has to be generated
to be curated, the ideas have to be
specified, enumerated
in order to be justified
or evaluated.
Dean, please continue on this.
Well, just just real quickly.
So we now have red and blue,
which was really,
really important to highlight,
that you need both
you need a minimum of two
for the explanation to appear
next deductive reasoning
and probabilistic sense, also known
as difference to the best explanation,
is a form of logical reason
that looks to the most likely hypothesis.
To explain something in an example,
did two white beans in the left hand
come from the bag of objects
held in the right hand?
Here we can see how the hypothesis
put forward.
Depends on an incomplete observation
or an inference.
Are there beans also in the bag?
And even if so, is that the source
for what has been transferred
to the left hand?
So again, temporal depth
when you arrive into a situation,
what what kind of background
and what kind of context do you possess
is going to go to this
this fourth form of logic or purse,
literally spent a lifetime
trying to defend a tangle
and then reform
into some sort of coherence.
And those listening
along may start to see inklings
of priors, sensory observations,
posterior updating of beliefs
about the world, even action selection
coming into play, especially translation
of the affordances, instantaneous action
availabilities into policies
which can be evaluated by their expected
free energy.
But we're going to get there.
Let's turn to abduction.
And here are some of the very fascinating
papers available on comments
related to abduction lot there.
And to kind of continue on
with one of the resources from comments
on abduction as practical inference
by Thomas Capitan, this work,
which we're not going to read
everything about, goes into a lot of
interesting points
about that dual nature of abduction
with hypothesis generating
and hypothesis selection
and distinguishes
that hypothesis selection
can make deductively valid evaluations.
However,
the creativity phase is non inferential
and that has a lot of resonance
with like not three censoring ideas
and having like an inclusive discussion
when brainstorming and recognizing
that there has to be a winnowing
in a finite period of space and time.
Additionally,
there's some discussion here.
This was
relating as we move back towards
or interweave with free energy principle.
Initial awareness of the hypothesis comes
with the observation of a call negated
whole by means of an uncontrolled insight
into the world of ideas
into what he called
third ness as given in perception.
The novel conceiving of any instance
of premise to citing a previous
part of paper is caused by prior
cognitions, hashtag priors.
Its content is suggested by the facts,
observations, sensory observations,
but not everything suggested is inferred
from the cognition of the facts.
And so Peirce goes on to describe
there are operations of the mind
which are logically exactly
analogous to inferences, excepting
only that they are unconscious
and therefore uncontrollable
and therefore not subject to criticism.
So leaving aside questions
like whether unconscious processes
can be considered controllable
here, we very much see hints
of perception as unconscious inference,
and we see also continuity
between processes of attention
and awareness, conscious inferences
and other subconscious inferences.
And so in a way, this is also providing
an integrated framework
perception, learning, belief, updating,
temporal depth, conscious
and unconscious awareness.
All these features are explored
in the person work
and the abduction paper is going
to very specifically highlight that fact.
Okay. Carrying on a little bit more
abduction and
retro duction, would you like to add
anything on this one? Dean
Well, I mean, people
that study and analyze this,
I wonder at times whether or not this was
a morphology
or whether or not
we can use the two terms
simultaneously or interchangeably.
Again, it's probably one of those things
where if you want to find out
what the details are,
you should probably go and have a look
because it's interesting,
but it doesn't at this point.
Are we basically want to do is
care I'll just read is
that your duction of the process
whereby from a surprise memory of facts
we are led to a conjectural in conjecture
lot theory to account for them.
Many logicians
refuse to call this last inference
because its conclusion is so excellent,
extremely problematical
as to amount
to little more than an interrogation.
I'm sure they're wrong.
However, they have not possessed
themselves of the true scientific
definition of inference.
So what he's basically saying here is
let's not call
abduct of reasoning, inference,
inductive
reasoning, the logical justification
of a retro doctrine,
of which the preclusion is that
the conjecture state of things is likely.
The vague sense of tended to resemble
the real state of things.
And this is the part where.
So what replaces that instrumental ism?
Whatever, whatever we define
as instrumental ism, this is again,
this is one of those conundrums.
If it's not if it's not
real state, is it?
What is it then.
What is an unreal or a non real state
because it's there we've labeled it.
What, what feels that.
What feels that eventually to make
the whole that's the question here.
And also again
worthwhile reading some of the prior
work of one of the authors
of the abduction paper.
And one can see in their research
a strong line
of developing and extending
and modernizing a lot of the work.
Let's yeah.
So I put down those bear signs
because I want to tell a really,
really, really quick story.
So if you live somewhere
where there are bears
at the bear
sign stays up, people begin to ignore
the actual sign object
and they no longer become interprets.
They they willfully lose that triadic
so if you're in the business
of, of animal welfare
and you don't want bears become too
used to human contact,
you have to be very selective
when you put the sign up
and most importantly
when you remove the sign.
So I wanted to put that out there
because that's a big part
of the objective and retrospection piece.
It's you have to sometimes
take things away for abduction to work.
It's the removal of possibilities
that actually creates an emphasis.
I think we'll just carry on to realism
and instrumental ism
because we're going to come back
to abduction
in the subsequent discussions.
More so, here are some quotes
from a fair event paper.
According to realism, such knowledge
factual
knowledge is descriptive of general
or particular features of the universe.
So that doesn't mean
that the model of gravity is gravity,
doesn't mean that the model of gravity
is what the objects of gravity are.
But a realist would remark that,
for example, formal models of gravity
teach us of the existence of objects
acted upon by the force.
Gravity and license the description
of a force which cannot be directly seen,
heard or felt
but still has noticeable influence.
Forces are real. Things are real
according to instrumental ism.
Even a theory that is wholly correct
does not describe anything, but serves
as an instrument
for the prediction of the facts
that constitute its empirical contents.
And so, again, on this Newton's
gravitation example,
the instrumentalist could take
the position there are no entities.
Gravitation, force and gravitational
fields are merely instrumental
applications of statistical arguments
or potentially even social
or power dynamical arguments.
And IT instrumentalists
may deny the existence of objects,
entities and forces.
In this case,
and even take things to the level
of having skepticism around words
as instruments and the relationships
around communication and how it orders
and predicts sense data.
We've explored realism in instrumental
ism quite a lot over the streams,
and we highlighted a lot in Mel
Andrews work in Live Stream Number 14,
one more
slide on realism and instrumental ism
and then either of you, please feel free.
All Describe
some of the bottom once again.
The map territory distinction is very key
to the real ism
and instrumental ism conversation.
There's also been a variety of excellent
philosophical work.
For example, a successor to the realism
anti realism question.
Those two, by the way, I would say,
are indications, whereas realism
and instrumental ism we are suggesting
might be seen as contrary.
And also Helen Long,
Eno's work on scientific pluralism
has a lot to say about this
by taking a multidisciplinary
lens on realism and instrumental ism,
and then, Dean, would you like
to describe anything about this top paper
you found? Oh,
I don't remember this in the grand scheme
of things, to be honest.
It's here for people to read.
There were many papers and again,
we're just putting a lot of text up
for those who want to pause
and follow the trails
and it all kind of gets enmeshed in.
Steven Any comments on realism,
instrumentals, them?
I suppose the piece that I come to mind
for me
a lot is all of this is that underpins
within action at some level.
So the the the idea of looking for
different contradict tions or different
retro approaches
could be a case of you imagine
when someone thinks about taking a path
through the woods,
you know, or you could
we embody a lot of these things or
and maybe everything at some level
is, is goes through some embodiment.
And when it's conceptual,
that embodiment is just happening
in a more conceptual space that doesn't
rely on as many other
kind of stories
or feeling your way through things.
So the the difference that happens
when you're in a field of practice
is that you're so used to being in
that field of practice that
that embodiment becomes
the water that you swim in.
And so that could be something
that sort of relates to this.
Break just in.
Just real quick.
So again, we'll ask at this point,
yes to realism,
yes to instrumental ism, yes
to the end, night or
under.
We had a little ampersand here
and we emphasized that.
And here
one brief note on for E cognition,
you won't go into depth here,
but for E can refer to as per the shavo
and von der Schiff 2018 paper,
which was in the context
of music pedagogy,
which is a very fascinating area for E is
embodied embedded embedded,
extended, enacted
in cultured, etc., etc., etc.
seven e 11 e, 22 e all of them.
And then a fun quote from Karl Friston
from our Applied Active Inference
Symposium in 2021.
He said, One key thing about active
inference
is it's it's beyond predictive
processing, it's beyond sentiments.
And it emphasizes or reflects
the pragmatic turn
at the beginning of this century,
really epitomized by the four E's
to make it clear that sentence is active
and that you are talking
about the circular causality
of engagement with any particle, personal
or with whatever is out there,
purple, circular causality
and all of that entails.
Then quite briefly, we're not going to go
into any of these details,
but here's a bunch of work
that's relevance for the inactive paper,
just some of the other
background citations and other work
that one might want to look into
and the objective paper
and also a little bit of leaning
even into something
hopefully the authors can unpack for us
on the the role and relationship
of Nominalism with all of this,
but many previous papers
by the authors here listed
and a lot of great work here
and so thanks to
you fellows for this journey.
Now we can enter into the two papers
or the space between.
Let's have an initial juxtaposition
of the two papers I'll put.
Our video will be the tip of the iceberg
here.
So, Dean, you're the tip of the iceberg.
What would you like to say
about these two papers?
In an initial juxtaposition?
Well, as I said,
I think if you actually step back
and realize that what people are doing by
by pairing two to active influence,
you are saying I have I have a particular
kind of situational analysis
that I would like to perform.
And in doing so, I would like to try
to remove contradictions
or I would like
to formulate integrations.
And if you step back to that, place
your your example of so your your hyper,
your hyper, your how your subject is is
situational
analysis, your example getting under that
you're
not now making the mistake of saying,
my way of looking at things
automatically negates or or turns
to other ways of looking at everything
that's under that title.
A Situation Situational Analysis to Dust.
Now there are comparisons and they're not
written here and they're already law.
And I just basically chose examples
within each of the papers
where papers are talking
about two different focal points, but
they're still within this larger, larger
marginal boundary of active inference.
And how active inference is behaving
around the behavior
within a regime of attention
and opening that up to something
more available then the specifics
or the scale friendly thing of
does theory of mind
necessarily blend with active interest?
Or does the idea that abduction
the moment when I arrive, actually negate
any possibility of using instruments
to extend my my sensory window?
Right.
So again, not going to spend a whole lot
of time pulling those other things out.
But if people want to actually see how
when you set approximately
two papers beside one another,
you can find a ton of similarities.
It's a kind of an interesting exercise.
It takes a while, but
when you actually see them side by each
and entangled, there's a
there's a lot of braiding going on.
Thank you, Dave.
Steven
yeah I like this
like with theme is talking about that
you've got these two papers
it could almost be seen as two icebergs
where the philosophies
have kind of frozen and given
shape and form and there is stuff
underneath and stuff above, but
there's also the water around in between,
which may have lots of shrimp
and all sorts of things strewn around.
So I think in this this list here, we've
kind of got realism, instrumental ism,
whether you two icebergs
or we want them to be nice and sharp
and maybe you get knocked a bit
if you bang off them.
And then your case and model comparison,
you know,
they they're still out there,
but they might jive a little bit.
Multi-agent belief, communication.
Hold on. We've got something flowing
here.
Things is assembles ensemble
so a model is ensembles
perspective or size
perspective of where
those perspectives coming from.
Why is it now in
stochastic AC complex systems
and so forth?
We're now maybe I don't know,
we're not dissolving the iceberg
if that's not about that
the iceberg there.
But we're there different types of
ways and of starting to
maybe be more flexible
and less stable.
Awesome.
So into the inactive paper we go.
So to keep things reasonable
and also have a lot to discuss
in the one and two, again,
we've put a lot of content
onto the slides
for your pausing and enjoying.
Most of the content
is copied and quoted from the papers,
so that is the point of reference.
To learn more, we'll just walk through
in the order of the roadmap,
some of the key pieces that the papers
go through.
So in Section one of the inactive paper,
they're going to begin
with a summarization of this year
at Ul's 2020 argument
for understanding others in the world.
And that's presented in this thinking
through other minds
to on paper
and then Tom is theory of mind.
They summarize
or capture the arguments of thinking
through other minds as one
premise,
one social cognition is an active
in embodied two and active and embodied.
The social actor cannot directly
grasp social cognition.
Three Anything that cannot be directly
grasped must be inferred.
Ergo, QED conclusion
in active and embodied
social cognition must be inferred.
There must be inference
about social cognition,
and the authors of the inactive paper
state that by premise
two and 32m joins the two M orthodoxy.
Understanding the world
and others to them
comes down to the ability
to infer and attribute mental states.
That is the summarization
of thinking through other minds
and they are going to call into question
on this critical dissection
that such a t to m
account is indeed making this happy
marriage with an activism
they're going to poll on. Yes.
And anyone or continue. Okay.
They're going to they're going to
they're going to pull out
on a few different of these premises
and what hidden assumptions
might be underlying those premises.
Like what axioms lead one to generate
such premises.
The contradiction
between P1 and P2 results
from two hidden assumptions
in that two argument.
So here we see P one, two, three above
and then hidden assumption
one Social cognition
reduces to information
in explicit propositional form,
mental representation and description.
They are going to say this.
They are feeling this way
as a mental representation
and hidden assumption to social cognition
is hardwired
with the concepts and logical tools
for inference.
For example, at birth
and in the subsequent sections,
they're going to analyze
and clarify the contradiction
between premises one and two.
This tension of if social cognition
is an active and embodied,
is it really the case,
or is it a contradictory claim
that social cognition cannot be directly
grasped by such a social actor?
They're then
going to critically assess
from the inactive perspective
what problems might underlie
these assumption, the hidden assumptions
and why, and activists
reject these hidden assumptions
and hence reject
the premises listed above
and they're going to be exploring
what are these non
representational methods and mechanisms
of code construction in social action.
They have a mark of blanket,
a representation visually
that we've seen here before
with the internal states external states
and the mediation of internal
and external states by blanket states
which as per the Perl 1988
definition, are the blanket states
making the internal and external states
conditionally independent.
Sometimes people go further and describe
a friston blanket
where the blanket states are partitioned
into two kinds of states
sense and active.
And those two kinds of states
are defined by their incoming
from the perspective of internal states,
statistical dependencies,
sensory states,
and outgoing statistical dependencies,
which can be interpreted as actions
or interface, is from the entity
or thing towards the neish.
But we'll come back to Mark on blankets
and more later.
Yes, Steven, go for it.
Just coming back to that
actually the page, the slide before this,
but relating to this is
when it says things cannot be directly.
There's a couple of things
that directly be grasped.
Well, I would argue that with that,
that's a useful distinction,
because when we think about what
we're talking about, the grip
and the grip to a pair of pliers
and I can't directly grip a hot point.
I need the pliers. I can't directly
to a number of
things without maybe more than one tools.
But there's a sense that
when we talk about grasping things
or when people are thinking about
if something is to grasp something
that is explicitly oppositional,
you know, we have other kinds of tools
that might be come into play
even when we think about words
and the act of ascribing
all these things can be
performances with tools at every level.
So there's a there's an interesting
blending going on here.
It's dependent
on how the iceberg gets melted.
Great in section two one,
which you can read in the paper or pause
here and capture many aspects of it,
they're going to question the assumption
that social cognition reduces
to mental representation and their point
can be distilled as understanding.
Others is a matter of being skilled
at shared non explicit meanings
and potentially some abductors.
Ding, ding,
ding and model based reasoning,
all of which are context, specific,
modifiable and dynamic.
And they are going to unpack
in the further paragraphs
that in there in lies
in evident contradiction
between those first two premises,
which is really like the Achilles
heel or the soft spot where they're going
to be targeting their logic
in section two.
Two, they're going to question
that second of the assumptions,
which is that social
cognition is hardwired from birth.
And so while they do
qualify the term position
and they say, Vasya,
do not hold a nativist position,
for example,
like a pure inborn perspective,
because they do have a focus
on the developmental
and ecological dynamics
of how culture is acquired.
They do call into question
the acquisition of the starter pack
and they are also
exploring more in this section.
Some and activist critiques
of, for example, hardwired
perspectives on social cognition
in Section three,
having critiqued assumptions
that in their mind highlight
the contradiction inherent
within thinking through other minds,
they're going to suggest
another relationship.
Oh, you don't like that dish?
Let's try this one.
And this is going to be a approach
Dynamical Systems Theory or DST,
they write.
DST, as we shall argue in
this section, is an approach that serves
to learn about and generate
predictive power about the socio
culturally situated practices of agents
constructing their niche.
Because DST
has at its core useful tools
such as emergence,
nonlinearity and spontaneity, etc.
It allows us to move away
from prefabricated notions, time
theory of mind,
like theories of social cognition.
One should therefore refrain
from making ontological assumptions.
Ontological here,
being about how things are in the world.
So more of the philosophers ontology
rather than the computer science
knowledge management sense of ontology.
One should refrain
from making these kinds
of ontological assumptions
licensed by realism
about the complex system
based upon the tractable model.
So just because the model is so tractable
doesn't mean that we have the license
to make ontological assumptions.
Since the tractable model
is an opportunity for learning
about the complex behavior,
only epistemic claims are allowed.
Let us take a closer
look at the claim to make it tractable.
We can represent a dynamical system
by a static relationship as follows
and here are their equations one,
two and three with the captions below.
And they're using these very simple
kind of like the kernel
of the dynamical systems
theory is understanding how
things are, a function of how they change
broadly, and it's represented
in a few different ways
in terms of a successor model
and more of a ray of change model.
Stephen
I think this is a very useful point.
Point number three there,
the bullet point, because it also speaks
to that sense.
So this is a model in approach.
Let's see what the modeling is telling us
rather than a model fitting approach,
which is often what ends up happening.
If you have the defined ontology,
you know, you effectively
pre assume so many things. So
that's maybe a key piece
that links a lot
of how things can be bridged
in terms of active inference
and how it could be held between,
you know, that that is a
is a stance in a way,
is holding the legs apart and saying,
okay, I'm not doing the split,
so I've got my legs together, right?
So let's find out than you.
Someone expert tell me
and. Yeah, thanks.
Thank you, Dean. Yes.
And I just want to add to
what Stephen was just saying
up to this point.
I really and I love the paper
that it's the constructivist piece,
though that I think
has me
pausing for a minute,
because I believe that in order for us
to be able to make that decision,
is it the splits or is it a fork?
Is it literally a fork and split
instead of having go left or right?
That requires a deconstruct
actually that I think is oftentimes
left out prior to a reconstruction.
So, again,
I'm not arguing with the argument
because I think
they're respecting the autonomy
and I think they've done
a brilliant job of saying, okay,
this logic, this deductive path
that other authors have taken
may not necessarily apply here
because it causes too much blending.
So good, good, good.
You're you're holding up
what actually is left and right,
but you're leaving out the at the
and part is it
could be a fork that I could
literally pick up.
And the only way you can see that
is if you can deconstruct
before you reconstruct and deconstruct
doesn't mean differentiate
that's already present.
Deconstruct
literally means just as the weirdness.
When did I arrive? In this moment?
What have I?
What what parts of the puzzle
am I still missing?
Because I'm in a hurry to figure out
if I'm supposed to go left
or right next, especially in social
context, especially there.
Yes. Stephen, if
you would like to give me the point here.
Thanks. You're just adding to that
that piece of the situation on this.
I'm believes that's where you come
into the weirdness of what's on.
So science is very much telling us
what's going on.
What is this thing?
What is this?
What is that?
That fork in, the road of being,
you know, a t t maize junction
or something else.
Ultimately there's a win in space.
Where is that situated
and in active inference that's often more
complex and nebulous
with the scientific
being about the accuracy of the method.
Well, at the time, as awareness
and the complexity comes in,
acting inference can have both of those.
Right continuing on through the latter
parts of the paper.
They talk a lot about complexity,
which many of us love.
So complexity, complexity,
science, complexity
theory bring so many great
turns, concepts, people, methods, tools,
ideas, everything.
And they talk a lot about other polices
and this recursive ness.
There's a lot of really creative linkage
linkages made in the inactive paper,
and complexity
is used in a really valuable way.
In Section four.
They're going to move into active
inference in an inactive dynamic setting,
and that
is where active inference is going to be
as an insightful instruments
to learn about and understand
the dynamics underlying cultural
co constructions,
considering it does necessarily
take agents as passive
agents together are the authors
of the states of one another
and so kind of analogous to the inactive
figures shown earlier
where we had the gears in the head
and then that went to like the gears
being more distributed in the body
and in the mind here in Fig.
two, there's more of a classical meaning
and model based reasoning
where different social actors are kind
of having this inferential account
that very like one directional
as shown here with an arrow pointing
just to the middle.
And in figure three, they're depicting
the social action in FIG.
two under active inference
in terms of labeling here,
the internal states
of the social actor too,
and the external states
being social actor.
One So this is from the perspective of,
of social actor to where
the blanket states are being framed
as socio cultural meaning.
And that model based reasoning
which opens up for inferential accounts
that are distributed and enacted and
hopefully will go into
more detail because this is where
they are supporting their positive
instrumentalist application of active
inference into the social inactive space
and then they write.
Characterizing a social scene
as analogous to scientific practice
is thereby a mischaracterization.
It's almost like taking
what happens in the laboratory
in a certain context
and even a certain view
on what happens in the laboratory
in a certain context,
comma in a certain context,
and then critiquing that
and thinking a bit more expansively
about what happens in the hallways,
in the laboratory, and in the basement
and in the world around the building.
And that is also really nicely connected
to some other Bromberg at all.
So work on the anticipating brain
is not a scientist,
which also focuses on
the inactive perspective
from an ecological perspective,
not only necessarily the social,
but the social is an important case
in table one.
They're going to discuss
a little bit more
about some of the dividers
and contents of cells
related to the natural world
and scientific tools and constructs
for sure.
We're going to return here
in subsequent discussion.
So just check out table one,
see what you think.
What other lines would you draw?
Would they be kind of like curved lines,
like look like letters?
Would you circle anything?
Would you draw some triangles?
Would you add another row?
Would you make it a tensor?
What else would you draw on?
Table one
even if only another double bounding line
to emphasize that it's perfect.
Does this then.
All I would say
is if you do go and have a look at this,
ask yourself why these hyper parameters
and why these laterals?
Because I think that will
that will lead
to all kinds of well, for me,
it just got so twisted around this one.
Okay.
And then conclusion,
before we move to the second paper,
we have shown that holding
both in activism and theory of mind
entails contradiction and confusion.
This is evident
when we critically dissect the two hidden
assumptions held by two and like theories
such as Tom, which are rejected by in
activism, those two cover assumptions
that they believe disrepute, the linkage,
and then they reiterate
the constructive nature and the embedded
in the ecological components
of social and action and the recursion
and the unfolding through time,
the rolling out of social and action.
And they suggest that dynamical systems
theory and active inference
instrumentally applied
as a type of dynamical systems
modeling has promise
and is a suitable and complementary tool
to consider social understanding
as generalized synchronization
held in a certain way.
So that was that paper, and it will now
be paired with the objective paper.
So one breath before we move into
abduction. Yes.
Even taking that breath,
that last sentence there
about how it can be
almost a bridge
there, that the complementary
use of dynamical systems theory
sort of fills a gap there.
So fill in the gap.
And in a way,
I think as we to at the adduction paper
some of the gaps that doesn't well,
I know we're not trying
to talk about filling gaps here,
but let's say we're filling gaps.
Abduction might also feel
so, you know, the the beauty
of the beauty of active inference
and the Bayesian approach
is that lots different
scales and modalities
can be weighted and blended to give you
potentially a feel for what to do.
Right.
So also doesn't mean one excludes
the other.
Awesome. Okay.
Into abduct when we abuse
away.
The paper begins with a relatively short
and very concise
introduction
to some of the key points of the paper
we described earlier in their aims
that they're interested
in this naturalistic rendering
of some of C.S.
Pierce's later, e.g.
post 1903 or post 1905,
mostly unpublished work
unpacking the semiotic
and logical notions, objective reasoning
which we covered in the context section.
They're aiming
for this biological model of abduction,
which is going to
thread the needle,
weave the fabric, whatever it is
that maintains
the functional integrity of the organism,
the evolutionary imperative
for that living beings existence,
and to be compatible
with modern neuroscience.
They focus on the allegiance and the
alliance, which we talked about earlier,
and they're all introduced
also in the introduction, the Markov
blanket concept,
which will be a great point
of juxtaposition to add a little bit
more detail, like if it is a front,
a contact front with active inference,
with social and action and abduction,
then these are like hot points
or points of contact within the interface
front to really zoom in.
Okay.
How internal state
being used in these two models
and that's where the active inference
ontology is of immense value
because even when people
are speaking in different languages
or we have a computer program
in equation, a poem
and then a scientific paper,
when we can link and proactively use
or proactively annotate
with the active inference ontology,
we gain the ability to not just say,
Well, we're both pointing out the moon
is your finger, my finger,
or are we pointing at the same finger
because it's so far away
and so maybe it's a little bit off
and your your ray is missing the moon.
From my point of view and so on.
Instead, we can actually get down
and not bleed out on the operating table,
but rather pin down transiently
and find a attractor
that helps us
really go into that intersection,
rather than merely hitting and running
with just points of resonance in.
Yeah, again,
I'll just summarize that by saying
we can situationally analyze better
because we now actually have a way
of being able
to hold some, some common
thing together.
So that's all I want to add
to what you just said.
And just add in one onto to
that as well is yeah.
So but
and where there may be a difference
so you know like that can
this understanding of a lot of the terms
the ontological understanding say
what often is a problem
is if there's something that's not
aligned but is just not noticed
was brushed over say okay
this is different.
Okay,
there's a nonsurgical change here. Yes.
And there's this there's a way for that
to be practically
like we have with active
inference is attractive a way to do it
because otherwise there's
so many ontological things
floating around in this space
which is its beauty
that it's it's not cognitively possible
to find what you need to look at.
Thank you.
The next section again
with these two lights
culminating co constructing
no two lights can physically overlap.
So there must be parallax
induced by these two lights and shadows
and all kinds of effects.
And maybe it's not the same wavelength
and maybe you're walking around.
Different sides
have different illuminations.
The section is
on active inference
in the light of abduction.
This is very fascinating section
because they're going to take that
almost quasi algorithmic
but certainly pre computational framework
being developed in the later 1800s
and, early 1900s and start to
interface and
see how it relates to active inference
so we can
highlight more and we'll look forward
to discussing in further section.
So do pause it if you want to read
all of this or read the paper.
But they're focusing on the late cinema.
Yes, please, Dean.
I was going to say it's mood lighting.
If you actually look down at the bottom
bullet, the lighting is actually trying.
I talked about it.
Maybe, maybe I don't know if he actually
did have the formalism to back that up.
But actually the inference actually does
now talk about the kind
of level of energy that we can now maybe
see within that the to
constraints
that that that that idea of parameter
ising back to the light script
sort of thing.
Thank you.
So just a few quotes
that are really fascinating here.
So in science, abduction
can be likened to the logic
of discovery of hypotheses, which,
as we discussed earlier, has a generative
creative element and then a secondary
selective component like Bayesian model
selection, Bayesian model reduction.
And they even add
with a cautionary remark that no fault
or assimilation of Pearson abduction
can occur to Ivy.
That's inference to the best explanation,
which is one
half of the two stroke engine.
And commonly people will use abduction
to refer
to probabilistic reasoning
from a given set
like abduction.
Elsewhere in the writings,
this late later skimmer,
those ones that are after 1903 that,
according to experts,
have been the least research ones.
There's beginning with an observation
of surprising
factor events.
Observation, surprise
and through a conditional major
premise concludes in a cohort
that of mood.
Again, a mood
which Pierce termed the investigations.
It's like it has and right in it.
And that is that
something of imperative importance
ought to be done
pragmatism in action.
Policy selection
initially aroused by curiosity,
uncertainty reduction, entropy that leads
to the formulation of a question
which is semantic,
and there's more discussion
of the investigations, mood
and other moods
adjusting.
One other quick thing cohorted
or CO constructed from the other paper.
Again, share a common
prefix that we again,
I think we'll maybe be able to tease
some more of that,
the importance of that
in the next two abstracts.
Awesome.
They're going to continue with
this question of the economy of research.
So they formed three
argumentative course,
really specified
areas of contact
with active inference and abduction
that they're suggesting form
an initial trio or triad
that will start to form the allegiance
between active and of inference.
First, the presence of non
degenerative triadic relations.
Then the utilization
of the leading
principles of abduct of reasoning,
the and third,
the subjunctive conditional formulation.
There are some logical technicalities
thrown around, but
that's what the streams are for
in point a
which you can pause and read the text of,
they're going to highlight
the Markoff blanket concept
or rather their realist
interpretation as Frist in blankets
and argue that the
of blankets again implemented
in a realist Frist and blanket sense
have a markedly Pearson
irreducibly triadic form
focusing on the boundary as mediator
between external internal states
and therefore the third ness
arising in some meiosis.
There's a lot more to say, but
if either of you want to give one more
point on a,
okay, in B, they're going to continue on
by talking about some of the guiding
principles of inference
and specifically discuss
abductions role in guiding inference.
What is the
leading principle of active inference
is then
here they're going to describe some
technical details of active inference
in terms of free energy, variational
or expected as bounding surprise,
and then they'll connect that
to some of the primary sources of Peirce
and discussions of bio semiotics,
which have also been connected
in a lot of discussions
that we've had on, representation
and meaning and so on, and
it goes even further or deeper.
A field where discussions of sonic ism,
as well as this question of universal
mind, which is for staging in some ways
the universal cognition, cognitive
dynamics, distributed cognitive systems,
matter is effort mind by Von Schiller,
and then they're going to argue
first in blankets and their construction
in terms of triadic relationships.
Pearson
triad sign object interpret aren't
leads to unexplored
and semantic possibilities,
bringing together some of
these broader
qualitative threads in semiotic analysis
with potentially dynamical systems
theory,
quantitative Bayesian methods
and everything else that active inference
brings
along with the toolkits to implement
and see.
They're also in C going to unpack
some extremely interesting
though
nuanced logical, constructive elements
of the semiotic proposition,
if I could call it that.
We'll go into it
more in further discussions.
But they're going to explore
how different
framings of relationships
among clauses or assertions in warrants.
And all of this
rhetoric relate to realism, abduction
and Peirce's version of realism as
the possible is what can become actual.
Yes, there are things that are possible
but cannot become actual.
And then what do we use for
that adjacency or realizable
possible and
where might we want to use it
and what's going to break that symmetry?
Where is pragmatism?
Well, what would be useful to consider
would be the space
of all possible, as that could happen
and none other, and not be surprised
by adjacent possibles
that we didn't consider but did happen.
And then maybe it's not so bad
to spend a little bit of extra
thought or a few extra computer resources
on considering possibilities
that couldn't happen.
But we wouldn't want to get lost
in the potentially
exponential space of possibilities
that can't happen
and end up losing our focus and attention
on possibilities that can happen,
which are what Pierce describes
as real possibilities
and the pragmatist stance
and mood also closes
the loop with policy selection
and pragmatism in active inference,
where they say that
the pragmatist meaning of beliefs
in the bean pierce formulation
is that a pond, one that upon
which one is capable of acting.
And there's a lot of resonances there.
Stephen
I think this also speaks
then to the need to have
we talk about scale,
friendly or levels or, you know,
some sort of structure
that enables this to be present
because you know acts inference
can so go all the way down in the
brought it down to the cellular level
this there's ways of looking at it.
Yeah there's a sense that okay
we're looking at these ideas
of a signifier
but we know we've active inference.
It's not that it's
believes that we have signals coming in
which get processed and aggregated.
So there's there's a sort of a scale
at which you have
the structures that you have the
the morphogenesis maybe
to get to an a scale to make
the stop sign make sense to be
interpreted
as a as its own signifier.
So I think that may be where there's
this tension going to happen
between the and activists here
and where that can happen.
But the argument that well, I would say
is that certain scales,
certain structures
and maybe certain realist
ways of things happening,
something like that
is feasible.
Great. Just Dean.
And then we'll quickly
move through the rest.
Of you ask me real quick here, I think
especially and B
and I know to a lesser extent and C in
the business of how we take Pearson's
Pearson
thinking into the activity science realm
is built on an assumption.
And that is that the key to our
our continuing existence, our continuing
reality
means that we're accumulating
more experiences
with the tools in the world,
the rules in the world and the pools.
And by I mean those aggregations
that Steven was just pointing to.
Thank you for bringing that up, Steven,
because that made me want to write
this now, aggregations as densities
tale of two densities materializing.
So again, I don't know
that you exclusively say
everything is real
and then all the examples underneath
it are also real,
because even Pearce himself said
that there is an aspect of this reality
which we will never be able to describe
as anything other than non-reality,
even though we're fundamentally using it.
So how does that how does that
enable these densities to form?
And I know that sounds
where the heck in gone out there.
I'm sorry but it's actually something
we have to contemplate.
Thanks.
They're then going to let the script
or at least the syntax
and talk about abduct
even in the light of active inference.
Here is where they kick off with that
acknowledgments of the two stroke engine
with generative abduction
and selective abduction.
And then they're going to connect that
to some of the ontology
of active inference in terms of
like seeing selective abduction
as a sampling process
and understanding
where generative abduction fits in.
So continuing on with
seeing abduction
from light of active inference,
which we might even operationalize
as saying like framing
or viewing abduction from the perspective
of the active inference ontology.
So rather than us self-selecting
as interpretations of active inference,
as some concepts
which we cannot necessarily
speak for a concept,
we can't speak for English,
but we can use English words.
And so analogously
we don't need to necessarily
speak for active inference,
though I'm the last
to say what those should or shouldn't do.
It's possible to.
Use the active inference ontology
and then it's kind of like a two step
checklist.
Was the term in the active inference
ontology
in the core supplement
or entailed sections?
Was it used in a way that was pragmatic,
that made sense
in that situation,
in that multiscale context
and? That
is actually a two step process to ask
if we're speaking using active inference
rather than if we're speaking for
like an advocate or like a salesperson
for active inference per se.
And they're going to restate the case
in terms of the FIP framework,
in the sense of and using the terms of.
And they're going to highlight
the relationship of internal states
to external states
mediated through the blanket.
And then then go through this syllogism
and they restructure and restate
their qualitative schema
of abducting, of active inference,
and they describe this action
cognition perception loop
where a surprise or any incoming
sensory information is experienced.
And then they take that
not just into the passive or even active
interpretation of it in the context
of a Bayesian generative model,
but rather something that is unfolding
in that mood of the investigate IT.
They do continue on
and bring in important person
idea of the economy, of research.
So we'll go over this again, hopefully
with authors.
It relates to Peirce's Theory of Science
Peirce's original paper in 1970
or 1876 on the economy of research
wrote The doctrine of economy
in general treats the relationships
between utility and cost,
and specifically
that is going to be related to research
in this socially enacted, pragmatic sense
by asking how given expenditure of money,
time and energy,
what is going to obtain
the most valuable addition to knowledge?
What experiment that my eyes could psyche
to will have the most information gain?
What could the researcher carry out
to reduce their uncertainty
the most about the natural system,
not merely to verify something they know,
not merely to falsify
something that they know
will be falsified, but rather to exist
in this optimal experimentation space.
And then Peirce and later,
the authors are going to naturalize,
contextualize,
bring to the social cognitive area
by asking, well,
how does money, time and energy happen?
Because that optimal experiment
is in cultured
and it uses energy, it uses reagents.
So perhaps in this way, we could say that
Peirce was one of the first modern
program managers
for a major funding agency.
But no, he wasn't.
And they discussed this
economy of research
a bit more.
They describe in this section how Peirce
promotes several
values or virtues
or qualities that characterize
the economy of scientific hypothesis,
making
in complexity, which is like a de-risking
breath, which speaks to unification
and caution
as the economic quality
of avoiding diminishing marginal returns
by skillfully breaking down questions
into a series of small
that can be answered
with reasonable limits of investment.
How many interesting threads
are being brought together?
For example, questions
that are broken down.
Binary? Yes.
No questions can be connected
to information, theory
and quantum as well.
Here's Dean.
I will let you
speak to fairness.
Well, I'll just read it, to be fair.
And as we began this paper,
there are no instrumental
misinterpretations of FFP
and its ingredients such as markup.
Like it's.
But this is a footnote in this paper.
But our face, for want of a better word,
of realist credentials of ATP,
has its roots in the pragmatic pragmatist
optimism, or rather
its active militarism, both against
and the alliance between evolutionary
evolutionarily useful processes
to contribute to maximizing survival.
If this pragmatist approach
to realism displeases
the elevated taste of one who looks
for some staunch metaphysical criteria,
let a thousand flowers bloom.
I think what's fascinating
about this is that
to hold the idea that there is a realism
is that it's a very easily
defendable position to take.
But even in the previous slides,
one of the things that
that first talked about without saying
them, or at least not in those quotes,
was that that optimal position
is some some element of exploitation
or economy or simplicity
or or somebody has done this book for me.
Is that a shortcut and exploration
which tends to take longer,
has more trial and error,
but also doesn't have you constantly
overfitting to a particular level.
So that's the reality.
And again, I wouldn't
I wouldn't push back on the claim
that there is a very real piece
to this playing
play, a minimum of two
going back and forth on this.
So I'm not
fact fully agreeing with these authors
like I fully agree
with the other authors about
about the idea of a code construction.
So I don't know that you you you are
you are necessarily confused
if you can say yes and yes and yes again.
Some even.
Yeah.
So adding to what the in saying there and
the idea of implementation
or exploitation
definitely has been alluded to.
And in science, there's experimentation
is sort of the way of gaining knowledge.
But there's the exploration piece
and I would argue that
you can't get exploration
per say within the kind of
objective domain
there has to be this journey
into the into the, into the performative
subjects, into subjective liminal,
as Einstein did
with his mind games over these.
And you create these
sort of mental constructs in a way,
some of what's happening
today is a mixture of that
and then that's brought back
and model would experimented or whatever.
And so I think there's
I mean modeling is interesting because
it's kind of can
come on that journey
a little bit as so that's
that's could be something
which experiments can't do.
Here's a summary of an old joke person
a says a and the referee says,
You're right.
Person B says B,
the referee says you're right.
And person
C says, Well, A and B can't be right.
And the referee says,
You know, you're right.
It's a little rapid humor
for those who like that genre.
They then have a conclusion section
and we have many questions and points
to make and a lot of connections
to bring back
to a lot of the naturalization here,
like the fields and leaven work
and they even take it
to the regenerative
capacities of flatworms.
So from flatworms to flatmates,
that's where we're going today.
And then we also saved up
for the Dart one,
some of the juxtaposition
of the mark of blanket concept,
specifically the social
and active components of science,
which are super important
and Magid has brought on
to these discussions
previously, is a great point of contact
with the objective paper
and the social and active paper.
Markoff blankets represent
like a very constrained, even technical
contact front that will provide
a lot of discussion in the dot one.
And that is where we close the doors zero
with again so much excellent
groundwork and backpack
packing by Dean and Stephen.
So is there anything else
you'd like to add at this point
or anything arising
that you want to discuss in the one? Yes.
Dean Then Stephen, if you'd like.
And your fantastic job
we just did in order of magnitude
three from what was typically
a single paper live stream.
Now we still got it in under 2 hours
that you're due to be applauded for that.
And secondly, I just want to ask
maybe as a bit of a tip off for the one.
There's a researcher
by the name of this disparate Nunez
who talks about if you want to be able to
look at how things are deconstructed,
constructed, you have to look
at both product in process.
An example being, how do I feel the car
and process in product?
What is what is the thing
that's either
a branching point or an actual utensil?
And so if you if you open your mind
up to both that conversion
along that continuum,
it opens up all kinds of possibilities
in terms of bringing things into a place
where they don't
necessarily come into conflict yet
they can integrate and break.
And so maybe that will be after today,
something that people
who are using active inference,
which in my opinion is both product
and process and process
and product at the same time, it's
the gripper and grip.
Maybe that maybe they will give
some thought over to that.
It's almost like the pragmatist
sees the fork in the road and uses it
and maybe
use the fork by going one way,
and maybe you do pick it up.
Maybe you use it by completing the table
setting for someone else
who will dine there.
And so there's so many ways to use
because use is socially enacted abductor
contextualized, etc.
And again, at the fork is where
that conversation is happening.
And at our field site or at base
camp is where we can imagine the forks
and the rows that will come across.
Stephen
Yeah, next in the dot
one sort of finding a way to, to
bring the authors if whoever's there,
you know, on a bit of a journey,
maybe down one of the forks,
maybe it goes to the edge of the lake
and we need to get in and get a bit wet.
So how can scientific
abduction or some of the sort of more
scientifically bounded
models, those substantiated
by experimentation and instrumentation?
Okay.
When when does that get moved away?
Maybe because of participation,
maybe because a transdisciplinary team,
maybe because of transformational
processes, maybe because of deep
exploration outside of the field
I wonder, this is something
I might want to think about.
How can we
give a
some sort of clear
journey options, right,
so that they can come a little bit off
without getting stuck
in, you know, in quicksand or
drowning in the deep water. Right.
So we want to sort of navigate,
but I think this this is given
some of those pointers,
I think where there is sort of
ways off ramps as well as on ramps.
So thanks.
Thank you, fellows. Thank you.
Thank you to.
This was huge.
I really, really appreciate all your help
great times.
See you in the door. One.